ma spécialité n'a rien à voir avec
l'identité des peuples ou quoi que ce
soit ma spécialité c'est l'informatique
j'ai un doctorat d'état en informatique
spécialité intelligence artificielle
mais depuis quelques temps sur tout
pendant mon mât mon travail à motorola
j'ai eu l'opportunité de travailler sur
l'innovation d'entre d'une ovation
soi-disant le l'art et la science de
résolution de problèmes et de création
de création de solutions à travers des
méthodologies bien connu donc j'ai vécu
pendant très très longtemps à l'étranger
au japon australie ainsi de suite mais a
depuis mon arrivée 2000 2013 mauritanie
g j'ai essayé d'entamer de nombreux
problèmes enfin pas nombreux problèmes
et quelques problèmes surtout dans le
domaine de l'éducation de la santé ainsi
de suite et j'ai profité de mon
expérience en demain d'innovation pour
essayer de trouver des solutions donc ce
que vous avez aujourd'hui c'est une
liste des en anglais on dit de taux
plein c'est-à-dire les 10
recommandations que je juge peut être
importante pour essayer de résoudre les
problèmes de des problèmes qu'on a en
mauritanie
donc là on va parler parce qu'on n'a pas
beaucoup de temps on va parler de
l'innovation d'abord en tant que besoin
pour un pays émergent la création de
de l'iki là on doit dire la création
d'une identité le la fête c'est pas une
création de l'identité c'est la
découverte de l'identité ce n'est pas
apparente mais si elle si elle n'est pas
si elle est latente donc on a la
responsabilité
s'il n'existe pas on a la responsabilité
de la deûle à découvrir ou de la criée
et finalement comment on peut utiliser
ce concept de de l'identité d'un peuple
pour motiver la population pour le
développement de son pays donc donc
l'innovation c'est quoi on va donner une
définition assez rapide pour le coût de
l'innovation
il ya longtemps fait pas il ya longtemps
mais à une cinquantaine d'années
si on avait un problème quelconque on
n'avait pas de méthodologie pour trouver
la solution donc il y avait un expert un
ingénieur un docteur et il commence à
penser penser pour trouver la solution
scientifiquement parlant on ne sait pas
d'où vient l'idée on ne sait pas d'où
vient d'où vient la solution du problème
mais la science nous a appelé les
généraux appris que c'était possible de
suivre des étapes pour essayer faire en
sorte de trouver la solution donc donc
c'est ce qu'on appelle en fait la
créativité la créativité c'est le sait
le l'effort qu'on fait pour pour faire
en sorte qu'une solution émerge pour un
problème déterminer l'invention c'est la
formalisation de ce processus donc si on
continue à crier a accueilli à essayer
de trouver des solutions pour des
problèmes si on est en train d'inventer
quelque chose de faire une invention
or l'innovation c'est la formalisation
de ce tout ce problème c'est à dire que
l'innovation c'est la formalisation de
la créativité et de l'invention
là je vais vous donner un deux exemples
un exemple la rapide sur la
l'importance de l'utilisation de
l'innovation on sait qu'un pays par
exemple qui n'est pas loin de chez nous
je crois que c'est le burkina faso qui a
récemment créé tout un ministère pour
l'innovation en ce qui concerne la par
exemple on a parlé de la créativité
c'est vraiment pas vraiment pas
théorique un cetain c'est un terme qui
devient de plus en plus pratique et on a
dans les dix dernières années on a
développé quelques processus de
génération d'idées par exemple de 6,5
ingrate les six chapeaux de réflexion on
a dit blouin a randonné importe c'est
des méthodologies qui sont connus comme
un docteur pouvait par exemple prescrire
un médicament ou une thérapie
donc il est bien possible d'entamer un
problématique quelconque avec l'un de
ses méthodologies le 6,5 ingrate par
exemple il écrié par docteur edward de
bono qui était un docteur un médecin et
il a il a profité des émotions humaines
pour pour les utiliser pour trouver des
solutions pour des problématiques connu
par exemple et là les chapeaux c'est
juste le fait de ces sont utilisés pour
représenter l'émotion ou la proche si
vous voulez bien donc on a les chapeaux
blancs lui les objectifs c'est à dire
que si vous jouez le rôle si vous avez
les chapeaux blancs et vous participez
dans une session de brainstorming ce que
vous faites en fait si vous essayez
d'être objectif de donner l'effet de
donner les chiffres ainsi de suite
chapeau rouge plutôt les émotions
chapeau noir négatif par exemple si on
essaie de résoudre le problème de 2
le problème de circulation en mauritanie
ce temps j'imagine qu'il est connu par
la majorité des la majorité des gens
présents ici c'est cette personne qui
porte le chapeau noir va dire non c'est
pas possible ça peut marcher chez nous
ont reçus sur le problème oui mais en
europe et ainsi de suite
donc c'est une le 6 1 c'est une
méthodologie de résolution de problème
qui est basée sur sur une émotion une
attitude
mais ce n'est qu'une parmi plusieurs et
elles sont toutes presque connu
peut-être le dit plus la deuxième et
l'utiliser par une société connue dans
le domaine de l'innovation qui s'appelle
heidi aux idéaux c'est l'entreprise qui
a conçu l'iphone la souris de
l'ordinateur et et pas mal de choses
qu'on connaît tous donc premièrement
c'est l'innovation
deuxièmement c'est découvrez ou crier
une identité pour votre pays pour le
pays
pourquoi est ce que c'est important j'ai
eu de raconter une histoire que j'ai que
j'ai pas vécu mais que j'ai appris du
japon dans l'air de mégi vous savez les
japonais ils comptent leur calendrier ça
dépend de leur peur donc on a mais j
choi s'est tout de suite maintenant je
crois que c'est ces essais si je ne
trompe pas bien pendant avoir l'air
d'aimer j les japonais n'avaient pas le
droit de sortir du japon et les
étrangers n'avaient pas le droit
d'entrer mais après leur magie du japon
japon s'est ouvert sur le monde et puis
le reste c'est de l'histoire on le
connaît bien on connaît que le japon se
développer d'une façon extraordinaire
mais vient la deuxième guerre mondiale
les japonais eu un problème d'identité
donc il savait pas ce qui se passait les
japonais se comportaient comme des
américains comme des français les jeunes
gens dans la rue et donc c'était il
avait un vrai problème d'identité donc
les intellectuels japonais les
philosophes japonais tels que tel que
nishida ont eu le stade ils ont eut ils
ont entamé le problème de l'identité
japonaise et ils ont découvert qu'en
fait après quelques temps que le concept
des vies qui sait c'est le concept qui
lie tous les japonais ce n'était pas la
religion ce n'était pas l'amour de la
technologie ce n'était pas l'amour des
sushis ainsi de suite c'était juste
l'expression délit qui élit qui en fait
c'est une expression esthétique nous
donner un exemple
ça c'est un kimono japonais il y a trois
façon de décorer ce qui manque le mono
japonais il ya trois ans on a trois
options on peut mettre le décor sur le
donc le premier choix on peut ne pas
mettre de décor si le cil de kimono donc
ça c'est le premier choix le deuxième
choix on peut mettre des décors des
décorations comme ça comme des fleurs et
qui peut me dire le troisième choix
assez serré parce qu'ils connaissent
déjà on est déjà expliquer ça à quelques
enfants mur donc le troisième serait un
nom donc le premier choix c'est met à
table décoration c'est normal ok le
deuxième choix sinon c'était de faire en
sorte que le kimono soit tout tout
blanc ou bleu et ainsi de suite le
troisième choix c'était de faire la
décoration à l'intérieur du comedy
kimono à l'intérieur du commun donc ces
choix là apparemment c'est on dirait en
japonais ikimono c'est à dire que c'est
un c'est un choix ic i ok donc c'est
juste un exemple pour définir ces coualy
qui est pour et pour le montrer un peu à
ce que le professeur le philosophe
kitaro nishida a pu découvrir pourquoi
c'est important pour un pays comme la
mauritanie bas se trouve que la plupart
commandes étrangers la plupart des pays
ont une identité
il y en a qui savent n'accepte pas bon
ça c'est ce n'est pas fait par un parent
spécialiste en sociologue ça c'est ma
propre c'est mon propos est forte donc
la france je dirais peut-être sirigu
peut-être je sais pas test le japon
c'est y qui les états unis d'amérique
ces voix qui fit peut-être c'est ce qui
définit ce qui donne une identité à la
mobilité aux états unis pour la
mauritanie on ne sait pas il y en a qui
disent le thé
oui mais pourquoi laitiers l'islam est
ce que vraiment à l'islam représente une
identité par mois je crois que les
mauritaniens peut-être ne sont pas ne
sont pas à la hauteur de l'islam sinon
on n'aurait pas des tribus on aurait pas
de l'histoire d' esclavage n'aurait pas
beaucoup de choses mais en tout cas
en tout cas c'est une question qui
mérite d'être qui mérite d'être d'être
d'être analysée mettra encore à parler
un peu de l'identité pourquoi est ce que
c'est important dans la motivation
moi je crois que on peut utiliser une
fois on a découvert ou cueillez
l'identité d'un pays on peut l'utiliser
pour cours pour créer une devise pour le
pays et pour motiver la population
quelle que soit la race la couleur de
peau ainsi de suite pour faire en sorte
que tout le monde travaille pour la même
cause donc ces mots là est ce qu'il ya
un
donc c'est moi la satim giddins tout le
monde connaîtra pas tout le monde ici
mais la plupart de vos peut-être qu'on
est timide et c'est quoi la mjd de
lakanal
sylvette degré active c'est quoi la
famille de daul a dénoncé djékou donc
qu'est ce que vous sentez là par exemple
quand vous dis qu aussi vous êtes fiers
de ce que vous êtes si vous êtes si vous
appartenez à la tv par exemple moi je
crois qu'on a besoin de crier quelque
chose quelque chose comme ça pour le
payer pour la mauritanie
je vous je vous demande de faire et
réflexions avec moi pas aujourd'hui
peut-être mais d'une sphère et
réflexions avec moi pour identifier la
timidité de la mauritanie
j'ai fait un peu trop cher je n'ai pas
trouvé de timides pour d'autres nations
j'en ai trouvé j'en ai trouvé des
slogans des motos mais j'ai pas trouvé
de team gym et je crois que pour la
mauritanie ultime du décès elle est très
intéressante là donc là je voulais
parler un peu du rôle de l'identité
pourquoi est ce que c'est important dans
le cas d'un individu
si une personne a une identité c'est que
cette identité est lié à son j'ai dit
igo ici god souvent c'est positif mais
moi je crois que dans ce cas là des
gosses et les positif donc aussi les
fiers de ce corner par exemple moi je
suis tel jésuite lg six mauritaniens je
suis machin et puis cette fierté va nous
motiver pour faire un travail
et puis le travail va
va nous amener à un progrès mais ça
c'est le point de vue personnel dans
dans le dans le cas d'un pays ça devient
un peu compliqué le progrès n'est pas
possible tant qu'on n'a pas identifiés
tant qu'on n'a pas identifié le
l'identité tant que l'identité n'est pas
clair pour tout le monde parce que toute
personne
elle va travailler pour elle-même moi je
travaille pour ma famille parce que je
suis fier de ce que je suis je suis
motivé pour pour améliorer ma situation
familiale les enfants et tout mais le
pays ça va être à côté
ok ça m'intéresse pas beaucoup parce que
je suis pas lié en fait il n'y a pas de
liaison
ok donc il n'y aura pas de fierté du
pays
alors on ne serait pas fier de ce qu'ont
de ce que notre pays représente et la
motivation ne puis donc le travail on va
pas vraiment travailler pour le bien des
autres qui vivent avec nous dans le pays
dans notre société c'est un vrai
problème j'ai vu je vais vous raconter
de petites anecdotes pour finir je suis
connue dans ma famille à dans ma famille
qui est quelqu'un qui essaye d'être
comme andré gide et à liste 1 et on dit
souvent de moi que le cadre des 6 10 il
est intéressant quand ils voient une
canette où il amène la bouteille avec
lui jette pas de la voiture de m
il amène avec lui jusqu'à la maison pour
mettre dans la poubelle est fier de ça
mais c'est quelque chose qui arrive qui
arrive souvent qu'ils arrivent souvent
chez moi
gg vinh j'ai eu un vrai problème pour
expliquer à mes soeurs qui me critiquent
toujours de cette façon nous expliquer
pourquoi c'est important
le simple geste de ne pas jeter une
bouteille d'eau dans la rue pourquoi
c'est important non seulement pour moi
mais pour pour l'heure pour la
population en général
et cet exemple là j'ai un problème mais
j'ai je suis heureux de vous annoncer ce
soir que j'ai eu un cas positif le cas
si c'est lui là ok bon ça c'était photos
que j'ai prises aujourd'hui je n'ai pas
j'ai pas trouvé la bonne photo donc j'ai
fait un tour dans la ville pour pour
essayer de trouver une photo qui est un
peu expressive on a un problème de
poubelles à nouakchott
c'est un vrai problème ok et une fois
j'étais avec ma conjointe et mes soeurs
dans la
turon passé avait des gens qui nettoyait
la poubelle avec leurs mains le propre
rôle mais y'avait pas de guerre pas de
masquer rien du tout ok et puis je me
suis mis en colère c'est pas possible on
s'en fout des gens blabla et tout le
monde me regarder mais qu'est ce qui te
prends toi pourquoi tu t'intéresses asra
est ce que c'est ils sont peu c'est pas
ton père c'est pas ça c'est le problème
d'identité mois peut-être je me sens lié
à l'intérêt de ces pauvres gens qui
nettoie le le le comment dirais-je la
poubelle avec leurs propres mains mais
je suis heureux de vous dire que hélas
je vais conclure que j'ai trouvé un
exemple super qui peut-être si les
extrapoler peut aider à trouver une pub
qui travaillent ensemble pour trouver
une identité pour notre pays donc
identité motivation ainsi de suite donc
j'ai dit à mes soeurs et ma conjointe
bain peut-être je le connais pas mais se
gagne ce pauvre gamin qui nettoie la
nourriture avec sa main il est peut-être
le voisin de votre bande qui travaille à
la maison et là je suis allée de dire
qu'elles ont tout de suite compris que
j'étais très heureux d'avoir d'avoir
expliqué un peu pourquoi il est
nécessaire de s'intéresser ou bien d
autres au même niveau que notre bien